I wonder what the actual likelihood of
of a real International conflict is
they they came out and said they
recently discovered that there were
balloons flying over the US during the
Trump Administration which no one saw no
one complained about and as far as I'm
concerned didn't happen it's like if a
tree falls down into forest and nobody
hears it then make a sound it's like I
agree I don't I I think it's just making
stuff up yeah but the interesting point
is so what you bring up a lot is that if
we if they came out and said hey this
was China who did this again you'd have
people screaming some kind of sanctions
at the very least and then as you
pointed out you get to that escalation
but I also have the semiconductor supply
chain war that we have going on in China
Joe Biden just had the chips act and I
think we banned all
um Americans from working in their um
semiconductor industry you guys should
look up an article and read more about
it but the chips Act is huge and um